i wasn't allowed to be a human i was a
topic of conversation and gossip and
punchlines it's just a few drops but yes
we do consume each other's blood on
occasion for ritual purposes i know i
can't
protect them forever hi i'm megan fox
and this is my glamour unfiltered the
first time
around when i was dealing like asked
with astronomical levels of
fame that in itself is a type of trauma
that level of fame is a traumatic event
my psychological type is not an
introvert but fame made me introverted
and if you're delicate or sensitive at
all i think it's a really hard thing to
go through and so i shut down a lot and
sort of retreated
from everything and was essentially in
hiding for several years of my life and
then
due to
unforeseen events um
sort of got drugged back out into the
into the spotlight again i think i'm so
much
better equipped now to
to deal with it and to experience it in
a way where i can actually enjoy some of
it i was
ahead of the metoo movement by almost a
decade i was sort of speaking out
against
some of the abusive misogynistic
patriarchal things that were going on in
hollywood back in 2008 and 2009
way before people were
ready to embrace that or
or tolerate it and i actually got
ridiculed for doing it and i think you
know people just had time to review that
like in retrospect to look back and go
oh she was actually saying a lot of the
same things that all of these people are
saying now and she was sort of
persecuted for that and it was probably
not the um
most loving kind
transcendent way to deal with her me
i didn't feel like i was accepted by
much of the feminist community me being
a mirror for those particular people
whatever i provoke
in them
is not something that they can
digest very well and so that comes back
on me as they reject me for those
reasons i just didn't think that i was a
very sympathetic victim and so i didn't
want to
speak out because i didn't feel like it
would be received in a positive way and
i honestly don't i still don't think it
would be i still do a lot of things that
are so provocative for some reason like
regardless of which community it is i
was being celebrated as being a feminist
until i had the nerve to call my
boyfriend daddy and then a lot of people
got upset about that which i think is a
funny conversation to actually have like
because that goes into
allowing women to be
women allowing us to experience what we
want and like what we like that that is
feminism i don't know if the
psychological breakdown was
strictly related to being objectified i
think it was more related to just being
dehumanized i have social media but i
don't personally use it um i have
somebody who posts for me and i decide
what i want to say and then but i don't
actually physically do it myself because
i think it's sinister i think it's evil
and
i don't think people understand we've
come to this place where we grasp like
bullying is bad but then when it comes
to a celebrity
all of that is thrown out the window
maybe it was worse back then i actually
don't think so i think with the
invention of social media it's so
accessible now that it's that it's much
worse but
it was more than
negativity that was constantly being
spewed towards me or directed towards me
it doesn't even require somebody to
actually say something directly to me it
doesn't require me to read it but when
so many people around the world
are
are thinking about you or have negative
thoughts or intentions towards you that
energy
permeates me it penetrates me i don't
have boundaries and walls for that i'm i
am still human i am still fragile in
that way i can feel
and
that that was more of the struggle it
wasn't related to anything specific it
was just that i wasn't allowed to be a
human because i was a topic of
conversation and gossip and
punch lines i'm just so much more
grounded and i i identify so much more
with
not with my ego more with my soul
and i'm able to separate a lot of the
things that are happening and realize
that they're not real everything that i
experience as a struggle or painful is
an opportunity for growth and
opportunity for a lesson for learning
for
for transcending and so my my perception
is different my approach is different
and that allows for my experience to be
different obviously i think there's a
fear that's very present so no one wants
to be the person to do something that
then it comes back on them that they're
outed or they're getting canceled in
acting at least in that part of
hollywood it has been one way for so
long if a woman comes on a set and is
like
i don't like this shot i don't like the
scene i don't like this dialogue we have
to work on this we have to change this
that's still perceived as her being
a high maintenance [ __ ]
versus when a man comes on a set and
says the same things everybody's like oh
[ __ ] yeah you're right no you're right
no you're right we got to rewrite this
scene it's not right he's respected as
an artist he's respected as knowing what
he wants that's still very present the
regret i have is that my personality is
so lost on people like my sense of humor
is lost
my intelligence is not
acknowledged sometimes i feel like i
just waste my energy giving myself to
people who don't understand and won't
appreciate but i've never had anything
where i look back now and i'm like i
really shouldn't have done i really
shouldn't have said because even the
terrible things caused me to do so much
work on myself i mean that's what
he says he says that he and i do believe
this was like even the day before was
trying to
uh basically quit the movie
and
his best friend rook his drummer and
then also his manager ashley were both
like by your scenes with megan fox and
he was like
ah [ __ ] it i'll get on the plane and i
had a reverse experience where i didn't
know why i was taking the movie i just
knew
something about i needed to do it for
some reason and then when i was in the
table read there was still one
character that hadn't been cast and i
was like
who's playing that character and they
were like oh machine gun kelly and i
like kind of knew the name but didn't so
i'm like machine gun kelly i like look
it up and i was like oh [ __ ] we're gonna
be in so much trouble because he's
literally like my exact physical type
that i've been manifesting since i was
four i'm also four years older than him
so i think i made him
my thoughts and intentions grew him into
the person that he is who knows what he
would have looked like or been like if
it wasn't for me i guess to drink each
other's blood might
mislead people or like people are
imagining us with like goblets and we're
like game of thrones drinking each
other's blood it's just a few drops
but yes we do consume each other's blood
on occasion for ritual purposes
only
it is used for a reason and it is
controlled where it's like let's shed a
few drops of blood i need to drink it
he's much more haphazard and hectic and
chaotic where he's willing to just like
cut his chest open with broken glass and
be like take my soul
let me bleed on you
it doesn't not happen let me tell you
maybe not exactly like that but it a
version of that has happened
many times
the most romantic thing he's ever done
for me that's hard to say he is
this is gonna mean nothing to people
that don't study this but he has so much
piscean energy he's so romantic it would
be hard to say but we keep this journal
that we've kept since the day we met
each other and it's just filled with
like our thoughts and our feelings and
our poetry i think pam and tommy were
twin flames i think that they were
soulmates kurt and courtney is a darker
version of the same thing so i think
when you find people that come together
that whose souls have known each other
who have like traveled here to do this
again there's something undeniable about
that and again it can provoke
a positive feeling in you or it could
provoke a very negative feeling because
it is a mirror of what you don't have or
think that you don't want i just think
that it's hard to
ignore
that kind of
a connection and that kind of
love regardless of if you find it toxic
or not that's irrelevant
we don't have like a lot of double dates
um we're not doing that every between
all of us there's like 900 kids so
people aren't really like double dating
out here a lot they're like magnetic we
they're like this all the time so
nobody's like really interacting with
them too much because they're just like
stuck they're stuck together like this
this is a very intense relationship and
it's cyclical and so it gets to these
points where like we have to do
cleansings i had gotten to a point where
i was like we need an adrenaline
injection of god in this relationship
and so we went to costa rica and we had
peruvian shamans who administered the
hiawaska
and
we each went in with different questions
that we wanted the medicine to answer
for us
and it was incredibly
intense
the whole experience like the fasting
leading up to it um the diet changes the
you're not allowed to drink water after
5 p.m you are in the middle of the
jungle and i had my questions and my
goals and then he went and he sat to be
given his high alaska and everybody else
was being given one glass of hialaska
because it was our first night and the
shaman says something in in her native
language and then the interpreter is
like we need to give you
three doses because you have such a dark
sad
spirit standing behind you like an
actual like demonic spirit hovering over
him
to no one's surprise anyone that knows
him we're all like no when i tell that
story nobody's like oh my god
everybody's like
and then what because we all we all know
that it
bound us together in a way like that's
an experience that such a few
amounts of people have in general to do
it together as a couple and then also
our journey that we were doing it was
affecting the other couples the other
people who were there so it was
prophetic in a lot of ways and it
confirmed a lot of things for us that i
needed to know or i needed to feel it
opened a door for a lot of healing for
me from a personal experience i had had
with him
that allowed us to
get to a place where we
were now seeking
the right outlets to heal moving forward
if that makes sense it is hard i because
i travel for long periods of time and
they
have to attend school which is what it
is you know i wish that i could take
them out to travel with me it would make
things a lot easier i cry often
every new moon usually i have get in a
bath and cry a lot about it because it
is
hard not because of pressures that any
anybody else or society puts on you but
it is just hard being separated from
them in that way they are my dna like we
share
spirit we share blood we share
they shared my heartbeat like
it's hard to not feel obligated to be
with them all the time or to constantly
feel like i'm not doing a good enough
job
but i'm also separated from their father
so i can only have them half of the time
that just is what it is
and um in some ways that allows me to
have
moments for myself where i can live my
life as me not just always being
someone's mother and that's nice noah
started wearing dresses when noah was
about two
and
i
bought a bunch of books that sort of
address these things that address
a full spectrum of like what what this
is and some of the books are about
written by transgender children some of
the books are just about how
you can be a boy and wear a dress like
you can express yourself through your
clothing however you want that doesn't
mean that doesn't even have to have
anything to do with your sexuality so
from the time they were very young
i've incorporated those things into
their into their daily lives so that
nobody feels like they are
weird or strange or different i can't
control the way other people react
to my children
i can't control the things that other
children that they go to school with
have been taught and then repeat to them
so that has been
a journey yes i do that's also why i
don't really
put my children on instagram or social
media like i'm so proud of my kids noah
is an unbelievable pianist
noah can learn
you know mozart's concerto in an hour
and just absolutely shred on the piano i
want people to see that but i also don't
want the world to have access to this
gentle soul and
say all the things that we all know that
they're gonna say i send my kids to a
school where
the other parents are similar in their
beliefs so the kids aren't known as nine
and the other kids aren't really on the
internet the same way that like most
kids are
so
they they know that their parents are
famous but their
knowledge of it is very limited i knew
that when they were very young i wanted
to try to protect them however i could
and a lot of that had to do with
limiting their exposure to the internet
um
so far we've done a really good job and
like maintained their
innocence in a lot of ways um
but
i know i can't
protect them forever
getting enough sleep that's obvious but
really being diligent about that i when
i lose sleep
um i can really feel the effect that
that has on my mental health and
traveling for work and being on
different time zones and how that
affects my pineal gland i don't smoke
cigarettes i never do recreational drugs
i'm always completely sober i don't even
drink a glass of wine i'm not saying you
have to be like that i'm saying for me
that that's how i feel the best um but
also self-care is
enough quiet time to be able to connect
to my
super conscious my higher conscious to
connect to god to connect to spirit and
this lifestyle makes that very difficult
sometimes and i do feel very lost when
i'm not able to do that i avoid my phone
as much as i possibly can all the time
but there are times where i avoid it
completely
the same thing with anything that has
like an led light in it and i just go
back to what our bodies were
were made for which is to be in nature
and to be
silent within ourselves every day if i
have the chance i'll watch a harry
potter movie
and they never get old to me the same
thing with lord of the rings like we're
a fantastic beast like that's always
what i'm going to put on above anything
else because it just gives me a place to
escape into fantasy and into magic
sometimes it's honestly it just comes
down to like
where it's shooting like i've chosen
things because it was shooting in an
exotic location before and i felt like
that place was gonna change my life i
did this with a movie in africa before
and it did and they're also the kinds of
movies i like making because
um i'm really good with my physical i'm
good with my body i'm good with stunts
stunt fighting learning weapons things
like that
and that gives me a place to express
my physical energy i don't really enjoy
being locked in a studio in a room doing
a lot of dialogue not everything has to
be a b side where you're like pushing
for critical acclaim i'm really not
bothered by that so i'm not always like
on the lookout for my my oscar
nomination i really don't care it's like
i like these big fun movies i just think
i would like to be remembered as
somebody who was
brave
who was
unafraid to
explore and become myself regardless of
anyone else's commentary but i also want
my legacy eventually to be someone who
helped others either helped others to
find themselves in a similar way or
helped others to feel
loved to to feel self-love and to be
able to give that love to their own
children and to their own family
because that spreads obviously and
that's what we're all missing right now